hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i've been investing
in properties now for 12 years
right now i'm standing outside the most
amazing building i've ever seen
as it happens i own this building this
is my castle ribsford house
and a lot of people i know are really
interested in this building and the
figures
the challenges the progress what's
happening
what i'm doing with it so yeah the gdv
right now is
6.35 million it's a big project
it's come with a lot of big challenges
we've overcome many of them
many are still to overcome so i'll give
you a low down show you around
talk you through the figures and let's
see what happens let's go
so when we bought this from auction the
biggest problem with it was the roof
because the roof was falling apart it
was falling down
and i think that was one of the scariest
aspects to this building so
we have now fixed the majority of the
roof
some of it is still off we've taken it
off completely and also the windows the
windows were mostly smashed
we've changed we've majority of the
windows have been fixed have been
repaired have been replaced
now we have to do everything like for
like because this is a grade
two star listed building we have if we
if we're replacing a broken window
we have to put a new window that fits
with the character of the building which
of course is
really really expensive but it's a big
thing
and uh that you know what i think the
biggest thing with this project is the
conservation officers
the council english heritage have all
we've built really good relationships
with them and they've been really
supportive
they understand what the vision is how
we want to restore this
the history to this building is
incredible you can google it it's got
its own wikipedia page ribs for house
you can see the three french soldiers
trained here winston churchill's visited
regularly
charles de gaulle used to be here
regularly in fact one of the three
french soldiers
actually came down from france to
mayfair
and took me out for dinner so that was
amazing but the interest from
a historical point of view on this
building is just absolutely immense now
i'm not really going to go inside too
much because
although it is safe to go inside it
wasn't safe like when i first went round
here
the roof was crumbling there was bits
falling down
it was also filled with junk like we had
to get so many skips
and it was really difficult going
through everything because some things
there was like old wet sofas
and rubble but then there was also you
know some quite interesting historical
paintings
so it was a real real challenge just
emptying it out
but we've now done that and there's just
so much sentimental things
inside and around the building which
we're not going to change we're going to
keep
we're going to keep the character but
also keep the sentimental thing so
right here you'll see there's a french
plaque and you know respect to the
soldiers that fought here there was over
200
french soldiers that trained here during
world war
ii and two-thirds of them lost their
lives in the war
so i've got i've got a lot of
sentimental feelings about
this building as well i know some of the
people uh that way
i just they say formulas not feelings
for me this is both
for me this is yeah i'll talk through
the figures the profit's gonna be really
really good
uh i'll make seven figure profit on this
on this
on this project assuming it all goes
ahead to plan which i think it will
uh once it's finished but also i think
just the
uh i i just love it you know i
absolutely love it
so what's this actually what's this
gonna be once it's finished that's what
you want to know
so okay this everything you see at the
front this is all going to be apartments
so we've currently got planning
permission for 10
luxury massive apartments
along here and these apartments by the
way these aren't going to be aren't
going to be small these are going to be
big they're going to be luxurious
they're going to be done to a really
high standard
and then all this wing here so we've got
planning permission for four houses
along here
in fact that's where simon lives so he
that house is kind of already there uh
these are ruins
so we're gonna fix these all up and
that's the minimum so ten apartments
four houses now we didn't wanna cram
lots of apartments into this
into the building but what we are gonna
do is
we've changed the scopes of the works
see when i first bought this that was it
ten apartments four houses easy peasy
now we've increased the scopes so this
is a much bigger project than
it was first going to be all the works
that we want to do
to fix the houses to fix up the
apartments
everything has currently been approved
it's been approved by english heritage
it's been approved by the conservation
officers
the council planning departments
everything's been approved
this this hot little hole right here
that's where the french used to stick
their flag
there was a french flag that used to go
here so amazing place
okay so these buildings here right now
all of these out buildings they're just
garages
so they're not attached onto the
building they're not really used
for anything apart from the storing junk
and at the moment there's not much in
them some old cars and
rubble and boxes and and these ones are
a bit bigger the
these ones i mean honestly
this is like dead space now previously
prior to the pandemic
and don't get me wrong the pandemic has
hit me negatively
but i believe as an entrepreneur there's
always positives and one of the
positives
is that boris johnson has scrapped
or is in the process of scrapping some
of the rigid regulations around planning
so it's looking likely and what we're
going for we're in conversations right
now that we're going to be able to
use all this space to build extra houses
so currently we've got planning
permission for these houses this
we didn't think we're going to be able
to do anything with this but now
the plan is to build a lot more houses
along here and there's also i mean bear
in mind we've got eight acres of land
so we're in conversations i don't want
to say too much but what i will say is
the scopes has got bigger the vision has
got bigger
let me show you how bad this was so down
here
you may remember if you've seen an older
video that i did
this whole area was absolutely riddled
in japanese knotweed it's great to see
that the death of the japanese knotweed
it is slowly dying
so they're injecting this regularly and
japanese knotweed
is a weed that you do not want in your
garden it can it can bring your house
value down to nothing
so there was so much japanese knotweed
around here
but the good news is the japanese
knotweed is now gone
so all of the japanese knotweed has been
destroyed by the professionals
i bought this for eight hundred thousand
pounds
people think a hundred thousand pounds i
mean in this area
around ribsford you can buy a house a
four-bedroomed house
for 800 000 pounds this is like a
20-bedroom
castle which we bought for 800 000
pounds one of the reasons was
because it had things like japanese
knotweed all around it now we fixed the
japanese knot which so straight away
i've pushed the value up
we've also there was a this this is
where it gets really bad
so the the building had some serious
structural issues
now we didn't know what was causing the
structural issues we could tell that
things weren't quite right there was
cracks in the walls
and we found a natural spring
just down here and the natural spring
was shooting okay shooting water
underneath the ground
at the foundations to the building now
that was causing some serious structural
issues
so what we've had to do is we've had to
go down we've had to
re-point the natural spring so now it's
shooting the way it should
which is towards the moat which
hopefully in time will bring water back
to the dried up mode and it's also going
to stop
damaging the structure of the building
and there was other things as well that
were affecting the structure of the
building
and uh i mean there was it was there was
so much damp
and i'm not talking down where the walls
are just a little bit black i'm talking
so damp that things are falling down the
roof was falling down because of the
damp
and one of the reasons for that was
there was trees
that had well this is just one of the
reasons that wasn't helping but there
was so many trees around there were wet
trees
pushing against the building thank god
that we've had permission to chop down
the trees
which has not only helped the damp
problem but it's also when you're inside
it's just
opened up the building now there's light
shining through the windows
and it's just got better views so that
kind of thing
you know it's one of those things it can
take months to get that sort of thing
sorted
but it's pushing the value of the
property up and up and up
ready for our end valuation and the end
valuation
based on what we've currently got
planning for is 6.35 million
i mean when i bought this i didn't
expect that when i bought this
i was thinking maybe the end valuation
could be about 5 million
best case it's now 6.35 million
we're also probably going to get scoped
to do to further the development to add
more value
i i wouldn't be surprised if this this
if this building ends up being worth 8
million by the time we finish with it
the challenging part now i'm just going
to be real
when i bought this i didn't have all the
money sat in the bank i didn't buy this
with any of my own money i got some
investors money i got bridging finance
so when i bought this i didn't have a
few million pounds sat in the bank ready
to restore this
and you know like most entrepreneurs and
like how i started my journey as a
working class 17 year old
you kind of just have to as richard
branson says say yes
and figure the details out later so
that's why that's why i mentioned right
now
we're uh working ridiculously hard we
are i've sold off some of my little
houses
put some of the money into this i've
also
opened up investors to come out to
coming on board so we're negotiating at
the moment
so fingers crossed man and i will keep
you posted but fingers crossed
we're going to be able to get this this
exterior finished by early next year
and then the fun will start when we can
start doing all the all the interior
work so once it's all finished
what's going to happen am i going to
sell am i going to refinance and pull my
money out
and you know what we've got we've got
different strategies so
i think there's going to be a
combination of there's also this
area is a prime spot for holiday let's
so serviced accommodation holiday let's
all the hotels around here are booked
we are literally five minutes from
budaly
which is a beautiful beautiful center we
are five minutes from the safari park in
fact
if you come here at 5 00 a.m and listen
real careful you can actually hear the
lions
it sounds like i'm exaggerating i'm
really not you can hear the lions
roaring from the safari park when
they're being fed at 5 00 a.m
so there's a lot of different
possibilities for this in terms of
rendering
it was you might remember this from back
in the day
the outside was a mucky kind of color
and we've now we've now got the color
which has been approved which is going
to be like a nice
kind of sandy gray castle color
the rendering has actually started we've
removed all the old all the old render
which has been pulled down
and uh we're gonna we're gonna get the
whole thing nicely re-rendered
which is gonna be great after we've
finished this in fact not even after we
finished
every project that i've been doing
because i've been working on other
projects
other joint ventures developments and
everything feels really small now
compared to this
like buying a house and turning into a
little block of flats
even building houses and from scratch it
feels really small compared to this so
i'm really grateful to everyone that
supported me in this journey
i'm also really grateful to the
neighbors i mean
one of the issues when you buy a
building like this in an area especially
when you don't live in the area i live
just outside of london
this is in the midlands is sometimes the
neighbours
neighbors
don't like you and make things difficult
so it's been great to just have a really
good relationship with it with the
neighbours thank you so much to the
neighbours they've been supportive that
have
kept an eye on the place uh we've also
and
part of that's two-way like for example
i own not just this
eight acres and this entire estate but
also i own
the road that leads up to the castle
and you know just being a decent human
being like we give the church
access to use the road and and different
things like that so thanks to the
neighbors
thanks to the builders there's been so
much work that's happened the project
management team ben machack and yanga
that have just been really really good
and
yes the scopes got bigger i'm great i'm
grateful to the builders also just
working with me
through this difficult time of uh
coronavirus and the pandemic
it's been i know there's been a lot of
builders that haven't had stock and
haven't had material and haven't i'm
just really grateful because i know
doing any project of this size comes
with its serious challenges
and this has had pretty much every
problem you could you could have
but i'm really pleased to say that every
problem that this has either been
rectified or has been identified and
we've got a clear plan how to overcome
it
so we've de-risked it it's now it's safe
you know now we just need to finish this
thing so whilst it's going to be a
little while before this place is
totally ready for tenants there are
tenants currently in this house
i'm not talking about simon we got bats
the bats
and the bats have got more rights than
tenants and tenants have got a lot of
rights
they don't pay any rent and we can't
evict them
we uh we've had a real problem with bats
on top of all the issues
with the coronavirus the pandemic
getting all the planning the japanese
knotweed the structural issues which are
all sorted
the cash flow from the business
continuing to fund this thing
the bats have been a big problem and
i'm pleased to say that we have now got
a license to work around the bats we
have to rehome the bats
but that's that's been a real issue i
think that here's the thing i'm pleased
about okay
whilst it's taking a long time i'm
really pleased of course with the end
value
i'm really pleased that we've increased
the scopes but i'm really pleased
the reason most people don't tackle
projects this big is because of fear of
all the things that could go wrong you
know
uh the issues like bats the licensing
the planning
the structural issues ending up buying a
property that's suddenly a lemon
we've got the best people working on
this in the country we've got the best
cost managers the best surveyors
and we've we've de-risked everything so
now
we know exactly what we're dealing with
and you know i just want to say listen
if you take on a massive challenge like
this a massive property like this is it
going to come with
uh with with challenges yes you're going
to learn a lot through it
and the people that are going to make
the biggest impact
and have the biggest businesses are
people that take on the biggest problems
and find solutions for it so
again another shout out to the team i've
been helping find solutions on this
i'd advise you probably to start small
and slowly get bigger and bigger
uh next update on this project when's it
gonna be
i reckon you know what next time i do an
update video on this
might be early next year we're gonna be
in a situation whereby we've got
i'll be able to tell you exactly what's
happening planning wise how many houses
we're gonna have
how many apartments we're going to have
i'm also going to have
completely rendered the whole castle the
roof is going to be completely fixed and
airtight
and we're going to be getting ready to
start going inside
doing the renovations inside the
property so that's what's next
thank you for watching the video smash
the like
drop a comment and if you're interested
in taking on a big project
or if you potentially want to do some
business i'm very limited what i can say
on youtube because there's so many
people
but get in touch let's have a chat and
i'll look forward to getting to know you
doing some business
and keeping you posted on what happens
with this fabulous building
thanks for watching peace out